ceci étant dit à cet instant je n'irai
pas par quatre chemins en lisant le
rapport vous constaterez qu'à toutes les
étapes de ce projet le manque de rigueur
l'opacité et je le dis la désinvolture
on conduit au fiasco
ce constat que je fais devant vous ne
doit pas et ne nous conduit pas
à jeter l'opprobre sur la politique
publique de lutte contre le séparatisme
et la promotion des valeurs
républicaines sur les réseaux sociaux il
s'agit je le crois d'un combat essentiel
et tout à fait légitime
mais comme la rappeler le Président nous
sommes ateliers au long des auditions à
interroger les faits leur chronologie
entourant la création et la mise en
oeuvre de ce fond et le constat est sans
appel sur la dérive de ce que nous
appelons un coup politique